We last popped up to the moon in 1972.
But now, the USA is going to work with Russia
to head back to orbit ol’ Luna… on the
way to Mars.
Is your Space Race bone tingling?
Right now, the International Space Station
is slated to be abandoned by NASA in 2024.
And, like Geocities, one day, it will just
be a memory, but now we might see what’s
next…
A few weeks ago, NASA and Roscosmos announced
they’d work together to build the “Deep
Space Gateway” a space station near the
moon offering a “deep space environment…
for human missions that push further into
the solar system.”
and to “the lunar surface.”
Does this mean we’re going back to the moon?!
USA (and Russia), USA (and private corporations),
USA (if this actually happens, woo!)
The gateway is slated to be a public-private
partnership where astronauts can try out technologies
needed to go into deep space, all while orbiting
the moon.
That said, NASA’s not really given a concrete
goal.
They’re not, like, testing specific things,
the announcements just said “new technologies.”
Russia handles docking tech, we’ve got orbits pretty much
licked… long-term space travel we do on
the ISS… maybe a new airlock!
And some kind of deep-space transport...
They mentioned “confidence...”
When it comes to specifics, it’s unclear.
Proponents of the plan say, we should get
really good at moon missions before going
to Mars.
Meanwhile, opponents say this could tie up
resources in Lunar exploration, meaning a
trip Mars could disappear into the distant
future.
The Gateway news should make the Mars-or-Bust
crowd nervous, because we were aiming to go
to Mars by 2033… but the Gateway won’t
be fully realized until the late 2020s.
Sooooo… shrug?
Going to space and trying new things does
drive innovation.
What will this new space endeavor bring us?
I’m not sure… without a concrete goal,
it seems like we’re trying out an ISS, only,
it’s a few days farther away.
Space exploration yielded satellite communications,
cordless technology, LEDs, solar power, water
purification, digital cameras, literally hundreds
of things.
I hope I live long and prosper, so I can find
out if the Gateway can live up to the hype.
Want more science goodness.
Click that Subscribe button and join us
We used to spend lots of billions on space travel,
so, what would happen if we doubled NASA’s budget? Find out here
So far, we’ve spent 65 billion dollars on International Space Station, not actually that much
The new F-35 fighter jet? 400 billion.